so where did this diet the ketogenic
diet originate from like when did when
did humans start eating this way
yeah well it depends on who you ask but
okay but we knew that you know going
back from scriptural times I think you
know the Gospel of Mark talks about
fasting and seizures right so fasting
produces a state of ketosis
that's therapeutic fasting birth or
starvation ketosis or fasting ketosis so
that we knew for millennia that fasting
had an anti seizure effect and
Hippocrates talked about you know food
is medicine and also knew about fasting
it seizures but it really went and some
people will argue the huge ate that came
at this point but it really the Mayo
Clinic in the 1920s 20 21 22 or Wilder
and colleagues really they understood
that fasting produced these ketone
bodies in the blood and that if you took
a diet and gave almost pure fat with
just a little bit of protein so enough
protein to prevent protein malnutrition
and the patient ate that diet their
their corresponding hormones like
insulin and biomarkers or blood
metabolites like glucose and and most
importantly its ketone bodies were
shifted in a direction that looked like
fasting even though it was you caloric
which means you can't fast you can only
fast for so long you know to control
your seizure but if you follow a
ketogenic diet you're getting all the
calories that you need for energy and
enough protein to maintain body tissues
and function and to prevent protein
starvation we do not need carbohydrates
there's essential amino acids from
protein and essential fatty acids from
fats there's no essential sugars
carbohydrates so we could eat a diet
that's completely eliminates
carbohydrates and feed that diet with a
macronutrient ratio which means fat to
protein to carbs carbs being almost
non-existent and maintain the patient on
that and they would
it mimics the the effects of fasting
it's much different than fasting well
it's different than passing but it
shared many of the metabolic
physiological and neuro chemical effects
of fasting you know the anti seizure
effects fasting so that was in 1920s and
then the diet was actually used as in
epilepsy therapy until about the 1960s
late 50s to 1960s and anti-seizure drugs
came along and they kind of dominated
epilepsy or seizure therapies and for
quite a while but they never really
worked that well they do there's about a
third of patients who just don't respond
at all they just end the patients that
do respond and still get a lot of side
effects in some cases the drugs are
remarkably well some people will say you
know be advocates of the some people who
are advocates of the ketogenic diet will
say the drugs don't work at all and
that's not the case because I meet
people where the drugs are really
life-saving to them but I also meet
people like Mike dancer who I connected
with if you just look up Mike dancer in
epilepsy you'll find his remarkable
story of you know a dozen or half dozen
or more medications that failed and the
ketogenic diet was really the only thing
that controlled his seizures and you run
into a lot of people like this and this
story that probably dominates is a story
of Jim Abraham's son Charlie Abraham's
Charlie was on a half a dozen different
medications for drug resistant seizures
and his father Jim took it upon himself
to educate himself about the ketogenic
diet and going to the library of all
things and showing his doctor telling
his telling Charlie's doctor that he
needed to be on this diet but he faced
resistance because the doctor did not
even want to put his son you know this
doctors patient on the ketogenic diet
because they thought it was going to be
too difficult to follow and the doctor
probably just didn't know enough about
it but even though it was the standard
of care so essentially he switched
doctors Charlie got treated at Johns
Hopkins I believe and
in a very short amount of time it
controlled his seizures to the point
where Charlie could be weaned off the
diet over a year - and this story was so
remarkable it made Dateline NBC and I
saw that back in maybe in 1896 or
something
and Jim Abrams is was friends with Meryl
Streep
so Meryl Streep did a movie about the
ketogenic diet called first do no harm
and it was to Charlie Foundation and
this movie first do no harm which really
got me motivated
I sent like all these links to my
program manager at the time and it was I
connected with the leading scientists
including dr. Jung row who was at the
Barrow Neurological Institute at the
time treating patients and also doing
science so it was a combination of
things in the media personal stories
people that I knew and I think most
importantly I mean it was really solid
PubMed you know peer-reviewed academic
research supporting this therapy it was
working as an anti-seizure affect
because it made the brain work better so
alright I knew it had implications for
other things but nobody else was really
looking at these other things so
actually one of the first experiments
that we did was actually a mouse model
of Alzheimer's disease we started the
intervention the ketogenic diet
intervention kind of after these mice
sort of have the the Alzheimer's
pathology which is these amyloid plaques
toxic plaques form and once that happens
it's hard to reverse but our studies did
not show it was therapeutic in the realm
of preventing Alzheimer's disease
because these mouse models really are
not very well suited to study the
disease but we did see an increase in
motor performance so they would run
faster and farther on like a treadmill
device we call a Rhoda rod so that was
very interesting and then but other
people have published including NIH
showing that the ketogenic diet and most
of researchers on a keto nester delayed
the progression of these amyloid and tau
plaques which are the hallmark
characteristic of Alzheimer's disease
but I believe they stay got ketone
levels higher and they started the
intervention a little bit early so the
take-home message is that if you have a
you know predisposed to Alzheimer's
disease
you want to it would be prudent to start
the intervention early and that could be
a diet that could be supplementation
what is the plaque that you mentioned
and and how does that plaque bring on
Alzheimer's yeah yeah this is like
there's amyloid beta plaques and tau
plaques and the the etiology of this
hawa pyth E or amyloid plaque
accumulation the reason for it happening
is a academic question that has not been
sufficiently answered yeah okay
and it's very ambiguous how these how
these things develop but you only have
Alzheimer's disease Alzheimer's disease
is defined more or less postmortem by
the by showing when you open up you know
dissect the brain and find these plaques
there are new technologies that are
emerging that are essentially positron
emission tomography or PET scans that
can scan for amyloid and tau and so we
have technologies now that can actually
image the presence of these plaques and
the the progression of the the plaques
over time with different therapies so
this is this is relatively new and but
some Institute's are doing this so it is
not really understood genetically there
are molecular things that are being
turned on that accumulate these that
cause the body to form these toxic
plaques but the the question is why does
the body produce these plaques at all
right right I think I think it's and
this is controversial but these amyloid
and tau plaques are produced in response
to inflammation in the brain and also at
the root of that could be a
dysregulation of metabolic control so
another hallmark characteristic of
Alzheimer's disease is a decrease in
glucose metabolism so in fdg-pet scan
which looks at glucose metabolism the
brain is very dim in patients who have
Alzheimer's disease relative to a normal
subject the image is much brighter which
is indicative of the brain using high
levels of glucose for energy a hallmark
characteristic for Alzheimer's is
glucose hypometabolism you need a robust
metabolic activity to deal with a number
of processes in the brain including
dealing with processing the amyloid
plaques and Alzheimer's and you know the
body needs to get rid of them through a
series of enzymatic reactions and things
that are cleaved and the glymphatic
system the brain has a limp sit so which
you know activates at night time when we
sleep so there's a lot of things that
we're learning now that could be the
root cause of it so it's the disability
to burn the your you're producing too
much plaque or you're not breaking it
down all sort of being recycled but
there's some of in that amyloid plaques
have antimicrobial effects so if you
were to have a viral illness like you
know is things simple that like herpes
simplex or HIV or a virus corona virus
yeah or yeah that's a hot topic yeah
Lyme disease like things like that so
there are there's evidence that Lyme
disease
the Alzheimer's pathology could be a
result of having a microbial
pre-existing microbial infection and it
could be viral
it could be bacterial but it's the it's
causing neuro inflammation neuro
inflammation is causing metabolic
dysregulation and inner and the
accumulation of these toxic plaques and
you can also be users genetically you
could be predisposed we have different
if you're an a phony for April 4 for
that genotype will make it more likely
that you'll have Alzheimer's disease and
if you reach to age of like 75 or 80
there's there's a pretty high
probability that you'll have
Alzheimer disease if you are genetically
predisposed and have the a bowi okay
genotype info you for or for for yeah I
mean it makes so much sense as far as
like evolution goes and animals go I
like going back to what you said about
physical performance if you think of
like an animal who hasn't eaten in two
weeks
right it has to have that extra boost of
energy to be able to catch its prey and
to eat and and you know having those
ketone bodies I guess in their blood
really yeah does affect them that way
well if I guess put it another way like
if an animal is in a starvation State
Ryan could not readily use ketone body
it's for fuel or be able to function
you know from a cognitive or mental you
know point of view or a physical point
of view in a mildly hypoglycemic State
and not have robust access to its body
fat and then the ketones that are
produced from that they would not be
able to forage and catch their prey you
know so they would not survive so they
would not evolution would not favor
individuals animals that did not keto
adapt we say right over time so I think
there's a pretty big component to that
but I think our modern lifestyle the
foods we eat are maybe lack of activity
mm-hmm prevent us from having limited
food availability so we essentially
silence that that that gene program that
would otherwise be activated in the face
of short-term fasting or long-term
fasting so when we fast not only does it
completely change our metabolic
physiology it changes our brain
chemistry the neuropharmacology of the
brain but it also activates genes so we
say it has an epigenetic effect and we
have pretty good evidence now that once
that those gene pathways are activated
it can enhance kita lytic enzymes which
you know are enzymes that allow ketones
to be used as energy ketogenic enzymes
enzymes in the liver that can allow
production of ketones under certain
states and then the transport of these
ketone bodies which are through these
things called the mono carboxylic acid
transporters like the transporter
proteins get up regulated pretty
robustly when you fast a person or when
you put them on a ketogenic diet and
then if they go off the diet completely
and then go back on again they are much
they enter into the state of ketosis
much much faster and so there's some
animal data that suggest that and of
course data in people so the more you do
it the easier it gets and maybe the more
benefits you derive from it - and I
think that is supported in the
literature now and also you know and it
kind of lends to this idea of metabolic
flexibility so if we're on a
carbohydrate based eating program and
we're eating carbohydrates continuously
throughout the day with small meals and
we never restrict it then we never are
making our body flexible to using other
types of macronutrients so one things
about one thing about humans is that we
are remarkably adaptable and we are true
omnivores whether you believe in the
carnivore diet or the vegan diet
plant-based diet I think the truth is
that humans have evolved and survived
and do so well because of their
omnivorous capacity and we do we can do
fine off eating meat and meat only but
is optimal I don't think so we could do
we can live and survive off eating a
vegan diet is it optimal I don't think
so ok so the optimal diet is the is the
omnivore diet so whether both sides want
to agree to that or not right it's a hot
topic